[Music]  nyle dimarco hits the MTV Video Music  Awards in style and has an epic response  for photog screaming at him on the red  carpet the America's next top model'  star who is famously known for being the  first deaf model to win the competition  took to social media writing in part  quote to the paparazzi screaming at my  deaf as ears you the real MVP that's  probably not the best way to get Niles  attention sorry not sorry  back in April not ET a thing or two  about internet slang in American Sign  Language of a bed and the Dancing with  the Stars champ also dished on whether  he has a real-life babe no no one in my  life right now you're busy you're so  busy so busy I know and you know I don't  mind I'm ready but you know I want to  just foster my career first I'll film it  later on yo career first people later  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]